ladies and gentlemen i have no idea what
the hell this movie is
here's what i do know stars mel gibson i
saw the thumbnail
it's called fat man and i said i don't
know what else we gotta do today but for
sure
we gotta check this trailer out oh yeah
i
have already made up my mind that i'm
watching this movie when it comes out
in the theaters i don't care where when
it's happening hey man gotta get your
your mail fixed if now is the time for a
comeback
i have no idea what we're walking into
but
crack of the fingers let's do this
people
i do
is
this might be the greatest movie ever
made
cold
this is what people actually think
christmas is a farce i am a joke
what's the purpose of your business
hunting i'm gonna kill some things
there is a rising number of our youth
made for decisions
[Music]
oh my god
why does this look so much better than
it should
[Music]
oh my god yes
i'm never key you think you're the first
my goodness
[Music]
donner uh easter egg richard directed
all the weapons
oh my god oh that's a new christmas
tradition right
i thought this was going to be like a
liam neeson movie and it kind of is
but with his santa claus what liam
neeson was santa claus and what if the
government had no other options
i love about it is it looks like a mel
gibson actually just
just it's pretty much just the mel
gibson action movie
and it just happens to be santa claus
with the title
too i was so surprised by that trailer i
know
i feel like we have somehow found some
rift in space time and this just
fell out of it because this feels like
something that should have only just
been a joke
but like you said it also looks way more
gripping and
competitively made than a joke would
imply
well it's tongue-in-cheek it's campy but
you also got you know mel gibson
and walton goggins who from the trailer
presence looks like they're hitting
the exact right tone it's not
too over the top it's just heightened
enough but they still
got this sort of sincere weirdly
lived in authenticity to the portrayal
of it mel gibson is santa
who is liv when we started calling him
like you know the legend like
what's the fat man legend man kevin
smith
yeah who are they talking about yeah and
then he's not calling kevin smith the
fact that kevin smith's
nickname is titles okay i gotta clarify
for you
all right before you get cancelled kevin
already covering a mel gibson trailer
and we're already excited for a while so
just try not to don't add more on top of
that this is the best christmas present
i think
at least you could have received you
know what's so funny about this
you always hear like oh is lethal weapon
a christmas movie
this die hard a christmas movie these
like gritty action films that take place
around christmas
this is a pure christmas action movie
what i love about it is
it's captured with so much seriousness
that's
why the joke is working the seriousness
of
weirdly amplifies the self-awareness if
that makes sense
it seems like they're taking yeah i
can't exactly find a succinct word for
it but it's that thing where you can
tell that behind the camera they're well
aware of how silly this is but they also
know that they have to take it
with a certain amount of straightness in
order for it to really actually work and
that's the thing is you brought up you
know movies like lethal weapon and die
hard and these these movies we love to
debate about like who's the christmas
movie because he
takes place at christmas but doesn't
really have any christmas themes or
spirit and this looks like
the movie to end that debate entirely
because like
half the trailer just does look like
just a male gibson action man yeah
except you haven't even like the
but then you also just have this added
context that he
is santa and there are elves yeah
and yeah and even they i like that they
kept that at least a little bit
mysterious as to just
how traditional the life of santa
and the north pole people are because
you know we at least see
a little bit of that they got all their
cafeterias sweets and whatever
you didn't really get a great shot of
the elves necessarily
gotta have surprises for this movie mrs
claus is a black girl here
i guess awesome you know if michelle
rodriguez was watching this video
she would say mel gibson is not racist
because look
he kissed a black girl yeah and if he
was racist he would have just
vomited it's not even something you can
control
bringing back another liam neeson
comment
it even reminded me a little bit of that
most recent liam neeson
trailer with cold pursuit yeah because
that
trailer had this wacky quality when the
movie came out i heard it was
better than the trailer looked but also
surprisingly funny and
and witty and so this almost looks
exactly like that tone but with
mel gibson okay that is not tom sagura
it just looks like tom segura and a
quick flash
well now i'm not gonna see it but you
know having both just the idea of like
mel gibson and walton goggins clashing
together here for this ridiculous of a
concept
that just sounds like a great time uh
like especially with walton goggins so i
think it's
uh we our next live stream is going to
be called underrated straight white male
actors
eddie and the man walton
he's still underrated and he has his own
sitcom that's going into his second
season
does he yeah i don't know about the
unicorn which i've heard
good things about and i had completely
forgotten existed until just yesterday
oh but mel gibson looks so committed to
this role i know this is the kind of
comedy he he
he should be doing if anything not
daddy's home too
which is another christmas review is it
harry he's found his market with the
christmas
well that's the thing is he needs a
character he can throw himself at
whereas daddy's home too it seemed
almost like it was
for him to just stand around be mel
gibson let that do its thing
here it's like he's gotta actually kind
of invest
it's like he always has a big beard and
he gets santa jokes all the time so it's
just great that he's actually gonna play
santa
there's things about if mel gibson
didn't have his like personal life to
boggles that have totally tampered with
his image him and kurt russell
would be on a very similar wavelength i
think in terms of their career paths and
they did star in tequila sunrise
together but i love that like
not long ago kurt russell played santa
claus and like a real santa
in that netflix movie now mel gibson's
play like well
this is the kind of santa i could play
so i'm going to play this guy to santa
we can watch him back to back to back
with strange imports and all those other
scary santa claus movies
yeah i hope this movie is really violent
that's the other thing i'm really
aiming for with this flip flick you know
it seems like it would be
and that kid is super familiar he looks
familiar he looks like he's having a
grand old time
right now the quality of the film looks
like a very low budget
film camera yeah i don't know what it is
a 16
or something like that yeah yeah and i i
don't know if that's going to be
distracting but if anything i feel like
it's all addi that's what i mean like
they're playing it so straight
yet that's why it's so fun melon
insisted they shoot this on actual
film and at the same time it looks
better than it should
yeah yeah completely perplexed because
this should just be a meme
yeah and for some reason i am very
curious to see how this film turns out
this will be like another random cult
christmas tradition leave your thoughts
down below people what do you think of
fat man subscribe click that
notification bell last but not least
i like to give a pitch in the day shout
out to pj
so last month we nicknamed you personal
jesus
uh before that it was pandemic jones yes
and this time around we are going to
call you
philosophical jew oh philosophical
jew that's right because you are quite
dedicated to the jewish
faith i think yeah you're assuming
yeah i'm 100 kosher you're acidic you
don't use electricity on the weekends at
all
if there's anyone whose identity is
constantly changing around here
it is pj a.k.a phantasm
uh juicy yeah a juicy phantasm man
a.k.a pure joy oh puberty jizzles
jingles is what i meant to say pretty
jingles that's the other word came out
get those puberty jingles just before
you start sprouting new hairs
i'll see you later peach love you buddy
[Music]